[Music]
I'm Michelle Miller from CBS this
morning Saturday in this episode we have
an assortment of stories on the arts
from a daring photographer to a
dystopian author to the history of
fashion illustration first we start with
a book about the iconic film Chinatown
it's complex history how it signaled the
end of an era in Hollywood and what's
next
Jeff floor has that story listen pal I
make an honest living people only come
to me when they're in a desperate
situation I help them out I don't take
families out of their houses like the
bums down at the bank J from its
earliest scenes it's clear Chinatown is
more than a place it's a metaphor for
the futility of good intentions hello in
this case for a private detective named
Jake Geddes played by Jack Nicholson
this business requires a certain amount
of finesse Nicholson then the cool
prints of a Hollywood system that was
about to come crashing down why is it
the big goodbye it's the big goodbye to
a Hollywood that made by and large a
great product for over a decade Sam
Lawson has been writing about Hollywood
in the film business his 2010 bestseller
Fifth Avenue 5 a.m. told the story of
Audrey Hepburn in Breakfast at Tiffany's
he is now the author of the big goodbye
it's the big goodbye to an America
before Watergate in America before
Vietnam so it's a big goodbye to
innocence said in 1937 the corruption at
the center of Chinatown is inspired by
real events from the early 1900s when
powerful city officials and businessmen
seeking water for rapidly growing Los
Angeles obtained rights from poor rural
farmers
the movie focuses on Nicholson's
character who stumbles onto a similar
scheme involving a wealthy businessman
played by John Huston you may think you
know what you're dealing but believe me
you don't and Faye Dunaway as a classic
femme fatale with a twist I don't know
what you were talking about Paul Koch
was Chinatown's assistant director and a
source for Watson did you know at the
time something special was happening oh
yeah the script was great and we were
all excited and we had the best of the
best in every department the movie was
written by Robert Towne and is
considered by many to be the greatest
script in film history
it won the Oscar for Best Original
Screenplay in 1975 conceived at the
height of Watergate the story neared
reality the more Guiness digs for the
truth the more darkness he finds at
every turn did it ever get any better
than this I don't know if it got better
it got different Watson writes that Koch
in town were part of a team that made
Chinatown during its time when Hollywood
was drastically more storyteller
friendly before blockbusters sequels
prequels and tie-ins nowhere was that
more apparent than at Paramount run at
the time by legendary producer Robert
Evans when he first got the script for
Chinatown it didn't make any sense to
him it was incomprehensible but he bet
on it because it was a Robert Towne
script and Robert Towne meant Talent he
said I don't know what this is about but
you guys I trust ya so go do it yeah I
mean if you're gonna hire Picasso are
you gonna micromanage Picasso are you
gonna say oh maybe you should use a
little blue Pablo here no JJ get us to
see mr. Mulwray then at the peak of his
powers Jack Nicholson is in every scene
of Chinatown but kaca is one of the most
important parts about Nicholson was the
environment he cultivated off-screen it
was his personality that just came
across and you you fall in love with him
Jack had that smile and that sparkle in
his eye that you you want to be around
him the other essential player in
Chinatown was the director Roman
Polanski
also has a cameo in the film yeah very
nosy fellow kitty cat huh you know what
happens to nosy fellas
they lose their noses next time you lose
the whole thing
this was Polanski's first film in
Hollywood since his pregnant wife Sharon
Tate was murdered by Charles Manson's
followers in 1969
three years after Chinatown's release
Polanski was charged with drugging and
sexually assaulting a 13 year old girl
he pled guilty to a lesser crime of sex
with a minor but fled the country before
sentencing I think it's impossible for a
lot of people to have any discussion of
Polanski the filmmaker given what
happened I would encourage people as a
lover of film and a someone who believes
Polanski's may be our greatest living
filmmaker I would encourage those people
to look at the work and and hopefully be
able to hold both truths in their hearts
and minds that he did this horrible
thing and made these beautiful films
reality includes both in relatively
short order after Chinatown came out
Polanski was out of the country Bob
Evans was out at Paramount Robert Towne
began battling drug issues that may have
prevented him from ever writing the same
way again
and a landmark Hollywood movie arrived
you're gonna need a bigger potion jaws
the original blockbuster as a 20-footer
25 you see a lot of money that would
normally be allocated for production not
going on the screen but going into
marketing campaigns the actual artistic
component becomes less and less and less
important to the bottom line and that's
given way to the world that we have now
it's a sad book
it's a sad book but it's not I disagree
that well thank you for saying I
disagree I think it's it's energizing to
read about something that someone's
passionate about well thank you I think
and that doesn't mean it's sad and
you're right you have to be passionate
in order to be sad you have to love
something you know and if losing it
means anything and that's what Chinatown
is I mean Chinatown is loving something
and losing something
wasun has a grim view of whether today's
Hollywood can ever produce original
movies like it did in the early 1970s
Hawke Koch is a little more hopeful but
it will be like this we made today boy I
hope so
I would hope so there are still people
in our town that want to make really
good stories we're storytellers
I'm very proud to have been part of this
man very proud yeah okay it gets
Chinatown
[Music]
after the break and author whose science
fiction novel depicts a vision of the
future that's frightening Lee familiar
to our modern-day lives
in the novel the warehouse a company is
so bent on profits his employees become
modern-day slaves it's a work of fiction
though not far from reality i sat down
with the author creepy basement very
free beneath the hustle downtown New
York City mrs. Weiss I do I do
uh this is my old desk author Bob Hart
shows us his old work digs to make a
point
it was way Messier when I was here no
working at the mysterious bookshop gave
him both value and time it was nice to
be able to go home from work when I was
supposed to go home from work not at
like 9:00 or 10:00 o'clock at night and
he took a pay cut from the world of
journalism to do it so by coming here it
was it was a chance to sort of like
exhale a little bit spend time with my
family which again is getting harder and
harder to do under this economy it's a
far cry from the world he creates in the
warehouse a dystopian cyber thriller
where big tax surveilled workers to
increase productivity and profits the
books based on this company called the
cloud yes any particular company out
there totally fictional minimally
completely in my head absolutely yeah I
did a ton of research on this and and
really it was reading about how all
these major corporations sort of treat
us like disposable products like we are
the food they eat to grow bigger to peg
it down to any one company I think is
almost dangerous do workplaces like that
actually exist the way you describe in
the book in large part yeah yeah so in
the warehouse there's a live work
facility it's this company gets so big
that they just build dormitory housing
for their employees so that you work
there but you also live there so you
never really go home anymore
and that's the Foxconn model in Asia
hearts world pumps steroids into current
workplace practices and unravels the
consequences
would Black Friday is taken to the
extreme actually covered a woman who was
trampled to death in a Black Friday
opening yeah at a Walmart I'll never
forget it
imagining a world where deadly
confrontations and stores during the
holiday season stoke fear in shoppers at
the end of every Friday after
Thanksgiving you see the footage of
people who are like practically knocking
down doors so they can get twenty or
thirty dollars off on a TV even worse
now companies are making people go into
work on Thanksgiving to start early
which is just really reprehensible he
also explores Big Brother run amok via
our smartphone devices you have an Apple
watch - yeah I bet somewhere in some
computer system there is a map of
everywhere you and I have ever gone
while wearing these and that doesn't
scare you it's terrifying but again I
have it and I wear it because it's cool
and it's fun you know and this is that
trade-off that we make where we're we
sort of surrendered a little bit of our
privacy for convenience it all spawned
from the chance readings of two articles
the first in Mother Jones it was called
I was a warehouse wage slave and she got
a job and a fulfillment center and they
were really running people into the
ground to meet these these insane
standards and yet people are still lined
up around the block for these jobs
because they set up in economically
depressed areas and I remember reading
that and thinking there is a book here
he filed that away until he came across
this New York Times article in 2014
Maria's story kind of put the human face
on it according to the medical examiner
Maria Fernandez died after breathing
gasoline fumes while sleeping in her car
between shifts
Maria worked at three Dunkin Donuts
part-time and it was just this
horrifying story the year that she died
she was struggling to pay five hundred
and fifty dollars a month on a basement
apartment in Newark and that same year
the CEO of Dunkin Donuts made ten
million dollars and at the end of the
day the cost of that compensation was
Maria having to sleep in her car it's
the same toil for hearts character
zhenya and Paxton questioning their
place in an alternate brave new world I
feel like your book is going to
force a lot of questions I think that we
need to start being a lot more proactive
than we have been you know I've made
compromises and I've made bad decisions
but I think that a really good first
step is if we just start thinking a
little bit so you want people have an
aha moment I could have written a bunch
of articles a bunch of nonfiction
articles about this the thing about
fiction is that it's about empathy you
know it's about sort of being in someone
else's shoes and an understanding
someone else's life it sits with you
differently it's a way for you to relate
to someone else's story and sort of see
those common and connecting threads and
and so that's why it just felt like a
fiction was the right Avenue for this
coming up the almost lost art of fashion
illustration that's right after the
break
they combined artistic skill with the
Flair of fashion illustrators were once
stars of what feels like a bygone era
CBS this morning co-host Anthony Mason
has the story with the personal touch
his late stepfather started in fashion
illustration working for magazines like
Vogue and Town and Country in the 50s
and 60s here's Anthony Bill Donovan
started sketching as a boy and knew what
he wanted the moment he saw Audrey
Hepburn sweep into a ballroom in a GEVO
she gown in the 1954 film Sabrina to me
you know she was a Swan floating across
the floor and I wanted to draw that I
didn't want to take a picture I didn't
want to design it I wanted to draw it
Donovan now artist in residence at
Christian Dior Beauty has drawn for
Vogue and Vanity Fair how many pieces in
the exhibition 63 pieces and he's
co-curator of the neck submission
fashion illustrators the visionaries at
the Society of illustrators in New York
what do you see in these works oh god I
see passion I just see the love of line
and color and shape and energy and flair
putting all those pieces together to
make work to me that is like visual
poetry the exhibit looks at a century of
illustration starting with early giants
like Carl Ericson who worked for Vogue
for more than 40 years beginning in 1916
and Rene Boucher who sketched many CBS
greats like Jack Benny and Edward Armour
oh but was best known as a fashion
illustrator the Great's all had a
distinct style like this Tod res drawing
from the 1950s I mean look at the
feathered hat it's it's chaotic it's
energized it's one of my favorite
drawings or Joe EULA holsten's creative
director who dashed off this sketch of
Martha Graham the brilliance of it is
the spontaneity the energy and you could
feel her dancing you could feel her
moving women illustrators were rare in
women's fashion but Barbara Pearlman bro
through I love this piece because she's
striking and she's staring right back at
you
some of these illustrators became real
stars most of them are stars most of
them are legendary almost every single
person we selected has a legacy like
Glenn Tunstall who made his name drawing
for the fashion bible Women's Wear Daily
in the early 1970s and I found people
recognize me
I would even get fan mail but they knew
Tunstall who came from Detroit was a
pioneer I was there as the first black
illustrator and womenswear was that your
dream job yes I think it was everyone
that was a fashion artist what makes a
great fashion illustrator it's this
fluency with drawing whereby not only
can you draw what you see but you can
easily exaggerate is it also during what
you feel enjoying what you feel you
bring your personality yourself into it
the commercial options for illustrators
have dwindled with photographers
replacing them on the runway and
magazines in decline is the magazine
market pretty much gone I don't want to
answer that fashion illustrator Sarah
Singh it still exists because people
want to do it and I want to do it why do
you want to do it because it's fun I've
had it ever since I was little that I
need to draw it's an addiction Singh who
works quickly in ink will then scan her
illustrations and alter them in the
computer she's drawn for Vogue Elle
Decor and Tiffany and also shows her
work on her Instagram page when you get
your work published online it's up
forever
before it might just end up in the
dentist office you get appreciated yes
you could appreciate it not fed but
appreciated
Singh says Bill Donovan is one of a new
generation of illustrators keeping the
craft alive a lot of people don't take
this seriously as art but I bet you see
it as art I see it as art and I've
always seen it as art it's a special
form of art that doesn't exist anywhere
else my intent is to capture a moment
when a woman walks into a restaurant and
she's beautiful and she just quietly
turns over her shoulder and gives a
glint so alluring and that's what I try
to capture that essence that spontaneous
moment that happens there's an intimacy
that is created when when you're drawing
live I think people want some of that
back our last story is an inside look at
a famous photographers journey from a
kid with a camera to photographing a
wolf on Sunset Boulevard coming up after
the break
his pictures of wild animals in remote
locations sell for six figures in part
because they're so rare and in part
because he gets literally inches away
from them Jeff Glor has an inside look
that makes the magic resist I've always
believed that the best photographers
stand in front of the most interesting
things it's really that simple
from the Arctic to Africa to the
American West
David garrow's work shooting wildlife
indigenous communities and landscapes
has reshaped fine art photography you
never know when that big male is going
to come a combination of his extreme
planning and patience that's it right
recently in Southern California yarrow
only had a few minutes of perfect
sunlight to create his latest print
shade right a staged shot on Sunset
Boulevard featuring one of the most
famous models in the world Alessandra
Ambrosio
a car and a wolf here ambrosia wasn't
comfortable sitting next to the wolf
come on you're fine if you don't like it
we can shoot them independently yeah we
just do a composite of the two euro
improvised you've got to get that wolf
further forward in the car you have
Sunset Boulevard shut down people
honking at you like crazy
a wolf four walls four walls he brings
back ups just in case the photo titled
Chateau Marmont was half of euros wolf
of Wall Street idea and homage to the
Martin Scorsese Leigh Nardo DiCaprio
film because our clients are already
answering the phone you all know this
scene the wolf of Wall Street he did one
picture outside and one inside a trading
room
[Music]
with jordan belfort
the man the wolf of wallstreet is based
on euros usual goal is to get as close
as possible to animals of all kinds that
includes traveling to South Africa with
British model Cara Delevingne to shoot
her in front of a lion you search David
Garrow on the internet this is one of
the first ones that comes up I mean
she's a British icon she is authentic
she is brave she's got a lion standing
directly behind she's fearless she is
fearless Yarrow has also come face to
face with Black Panthers elephants
captured here with a special wide-angle
lens and tigers targets will kill you
Tigers the most vicious animals in the
world they will kill you for fun I'll go
in the cage I think and try and work
from the cage is there ever any fear
this fear of failure which is always
good but at fear of personal safety
never with animals with people yes I
mean my scary moments have always been
with people because people can buy weed
they can get drunk and making buy guns
how animals can do those three things
one of euros most famous photos is a
kind of selfie with a polar bear where
if you look closely you can see his
silhouette in the Bears eyes I heard
somebody say once that most people
survive attacks with black bears or
Grizzlies but nobody's ever survived an
attack from a polar bear I think that's
probably probably true and yet you're
right there in its face well we do worse
than we do more than that because
they're very sweet tooth so you've
always got to be done you've got to be
downwind from them never be upwind from
the polar bear because they wouldn't
smell you but if you're downwind and
then you cover yourself in chocolate but
we always say don't don't do it at home
David euro first became interested in
photography as a teenager snapping
pictures of sporting events in England
but following parental and economic
pressure he shifted to banking way back
in 1988 photography was something that
weird people did like they were big
train spotters whereas banking is what
normal people do and now banking is what
weird people do and photography is what
normal people there is amazing how far
we've come
the arrow didn't get back to photography
full-time until 2012 by that time his
marriage had painfully fallen apart I
wasn't fond of myself my path to
redemption was to pick up my cameras and
go to the most remote parts of the world
that was the way that was my antidote my
personal pain euro has cultivated an
impressive list of celebrity fans by now
Tom Brady wrote the foreword to his
latest book when people want to say
something nasty about me they'll turn
right David yeah he's he's taking some
good pictures but you know he's a
businessman my mother was an artist
using much better artists and mere
sculptures and she she died sadly
penniless because she thought that the
commercial pursuit or the monetization
of her craft was shameless I don't know
let's be shameless let's just that's
we've got it we've got a van and that's
how you feel about it when people say
that there's more interest in the
celebrity or that were the business part
of it than the actual art itself I think
you have to have a night market if
people want to if people want to turn
around and say yeah well David Yates he
knows the American football players and
British football players and supermodel
whatever I work with them I think you've
done a remarkable job hero can take
months to plan one picture but once
everything is in place things move fast
from Sunset Boulevard to here yeah and
we pride ourselves on our work I think
we show this 26 hours ago and here is
the final version he then only releases
a limited number of original sign
pictures single prints can go for well
over $100,000 do you ever stop to think
about that that you're producing
pictures that they demand that amount of
money in 1985 I photograph Wimbledon I
go home I would print up my pictures in
the darkroom and I would sell them on
the streets
the next day for 20 quid a picture
so when you go from selling pitches on
the street for 20 quid to seeing one of
your pitchers guess other bees of course
you think about the fact that your
journey is as worked and your hard work
paid off so that garnish do I go to bed
thinking about it no I just want to get
better you can find news and more
stories like this on CBS this morning
Saturday every weekend and join us right
here on CBS n for live coverage of news
24/7 available for free across all
platforms
I'm Michelle Miller